there is one particularly salient
question we should ask in order to
measure our levels of emotional
well-being do you broadly feel that you
have the right to exist and are on
balance a good enough human being oh
whatever your outward circumstances and
achievements do you generally feel
you're a piece of excrement who's only
got through life by deluding others who
would quickly abandon you if ever they
knew even a fraction of the truth about
you and because you're a liar are you
only ever one or two steps away from a
feeling of deserved humiliation and
catastrophe it is in a sense
extraordinary how many of us
instinctively answer yes to the second
question in other words how many of us
are alive without a sense that we have
any genuine merit in walking on the
earth suicide statistics say something
horrifying about our societies but the
numbers on violent self-hatred from
which one in four of us are estimated to
suffer say something arguably even worse
if we saw a stranger being treated the
way many of us treat ourselves we
wouldn't hesitate to call it wanton
cruelty an odd detail about disliking
oneself is that one generally doesn't
even notice oneself doing it realizing
it would require a degree of objectivity
about one's potential worth that one
precisely lacks self hatred can be too
obvious to be visible it's the default
position and has been since childhood
one doesn't identify as a self dislike
er one just thinks wants a piece of [ __ ]
the feeling radiates its effects in a
number of areas if someone pays you a
compliment you immediately doubt their
intelligence when someone offers to love
you you wonder why they're so weak when
you're stuck in a frustrating
relationship but work or in private life
you stay if necessary for decades
because this is after all simply what
you deserve if you're promoted or are
admired you at once feel incapable and a
liar there's a voice in your head that
accompanies you in all challenges and
tells you you're not going to be able to
do this your room
[ __ ] and everyone hates you if
something appears to go well you'll
sabotage things brilliantly you know
just how to screw up job opportunities
and drive away people who want to be
kind you easily feel that people are
mocking and mistreating you you sense
hostility and interactions in shops or
restaurants with colleagues or lovers a
lot of the time you're in a paranoid
frame of mind out of a fear that the
world might at any point discover or has
already discovered what you well know
about yourself that you're a disgusting
imbecile salvation starts with an
obvious sounding insight that should
nevertheless be written in large letters
across the sky no one is born liking
themselves that is there's a history to
this which you've been left unable to
think about it's only for soothing
enthusiastic responses of our earliest
caregivers that can lend us any of the
encouragement we need to carry on our
sense of self is assembled out of the
reactions of those who were first around
us we may not know anything about these
people in conscious memory but we don't
need to we can deduce everything vital
by asking ourselves the very simple
question do I like Who I am you may not
have the original mold at hand but you
can sense the imprint in the dough of
your character no one can survive the
sense that they were a bore a threat and
inconvenience or a disappointment to
those who made them this isn't some
negotiable point if you are in this
wretched camp you get a prize for not
having done away with yourself already
we can't escape a basic law we are the
only animal whose sense of being able to
keep on keeping on depends on the
Welcome accorded to them by those who
made them it's so horrific to have to
acknowledge that we were badly or
unfairly treated in an especially
bizarre phenomenon we're liable to turn
the anger we might in theory feel
towards our erstwhile flawed caregivers
back onto ourselves we end up preferring
to dislike who we are rather than
accepting a yet more horrible idea that
someone we needed to adore wasn't very
nice to us we can end up lacking any
capacity for anger because that would
require a basic sense of self-worth and
therefore an idea that we had been
violated most of us are just numb or in
an effort to feel numb
we gorge on drugs on porn love affairs
Fame or processed sugar the path of
self-hatred points everywhere other than
to its real source those early years so
how does one ever dig oneself out of the
mineshaft of self-hatred well for a
start by becoming a better historian of
ourselves and therefore being able to
hold on to the idea that we hate
ourselves only or primarily because we
were once not loved but this has a
structure so basic it feels like an
insult but to make this concept resonate
with one's actual experience that can be
the task of a lifetime we need to start
to notice what unfair storytellers we
are how many decades of practice we've
had are always turning ourselves into
the villain of justifying the behavior
of others way beyond what they deserved
and putting ourselves invariably at
shameful fault we may be very clever but
in this area we probably can't even
think too clearly so we may need to
bring in another brain to help our
faltering one out we may need to check
our reality against another's and
thereby recalibrate our assessment of
everything we've touched
we need to repatriate the pain away from
hating ourselves and fearing the world
towards morning and original catastrophe
we may eventually reach a very weird
sounding insight that we aren't
exceptionally awful
we just had an exceptionally unfortunate
introduction to life we need to learn a
vital art from which so much else can
then flow that of being a little bit
more on our own side visit our shop to
give a life-changing gift the School of
Life offers a wide range of thoughtful
pract
and genuinely useful gifts designed to
help us solve some of the most common
and intractable problems of life click
now to learn more